Now I’d like to introduce
today’s presenters.
Neil Daswani is an instructor and
co-director for
the Stanford Advanced Computer
Security Certificate.
In the past he has served in a variety
of research, development, teaching,
and managerial roles at Twitter, Dasient,
Google, and Stanford University.
Neil is also a co-author of “Foundations
of Security – What every Programmer Needs
to Know”, and has published extensively
in these areas having been quoted by
publications such as the New York Times,
USA Today, and CSO Magazine.
Neil earned his PhD and MS degrees
in computer science at Stanford, and
he holds a BS in computer science
with honors from Columbia.
Now I’d like to turn
the floor over to Neil.
Great, thank you very much for
that introduction Joe.
In addition to the company that
you mentioned, I've also served
in managerial roles In the area of
security both at LifeLock and Symantec,
and I'm thrilled to be chatting
with all of you today about some of
the big name breaches that have
taken place over the past few years.
If we look at what's gone on in
the field for the past 15 years,
there have been more than a billion
customer records that have been stolen.
There have been thousands
upon thousand of breeches
that have impacted many organizations,
and so
there's a lot to be learned
from these breeches.
One of the reasons that I think it's
important to make sure we cover these
kinds of lessons and that we can all learn
from these lessons is because there's this
adage that those who don't know history
are doomed to repeat it and I think
even when you know all the lessons,
We'll look at various world leaders.
They're very aware of history, and still,
it can be challenging to keep
one's self out of trouble.
Given what's taken place in the industry,
there's a lot to be learned.
There's lot of organizations that have
been victimized by significant breaches.
And the ones that we highlight here
are not ones that we're talking about
to shame any of them, but rather,
I think, as a community of enterprises,
we need to all get better and
be able to be on a path of continual
improvement with regards to security, so
that we can combat some of
the adversaries, whether they
be organized separate criminal groups,
or potentially even nation-states.
So let's go ahead and
start by covering a few of
the breaches that have just occurred
in the first five months of this year.
And I'm going to cover not only
two breaches but one incident
that may not be considered a breach and
I'll talk a little bit about why that is.
But if we just look at the first five
months of 2017, there have been over 243
breaches per data from the breach
database at privacyrights.org.
And overall, the MO, or the modus
operandi, for some of these breaches
has been similar to what they have been,
I'd say over the past four to five years.
The slide around here on the left
talks about the attacker life cycle,
and I'll cover that in a bit more detail.
Let me chat a little bit about
some of the more recent breaches.
One of the organizations that was impacted
by a breach earlier this year is Dun and
Bradstreet.
Some of you may have heard of Dun and
They are an organization that tracks
information about businesses mostly for
the purpose of helping other organizations
assess the credit worthiness
of those businesses.
They also happen to have databases
of large numbers of individuals
in corporate America,
from CEOs to Executive Vice Presidents,
Senior Vice Presidents to managers
across their organization, and
one of the issues that occurred earlier
this year in March is that it appears that
their database of individuals
in corporate America was stolen.
Now Dun and Bradstreet as a company
sells that database to a number of other
organizations and from statements
that Dun and Bradstreet have made,
they don't believe that it was their
information security countermeasures that
were breached, but they sell this data to
a whole bunch of other organizations and
they believe that it was actually
one of the other organizations,
one of the customers that were breached.
And so one of the things that we
will see in some of the other big
name breaches that I'm going to talk
about a little bit later is that vetting
your third-party suppliers has
become more and more important.
We'll talk about that in relation to,
for instance, the Target breach in a few
minutes, but what's interesting about
the Dun and Bradstreet breach is that it
may have been the security of one of
their customers that was breached.
And so typically when you buy
something from a company,
you think about okay you need to vet
their information security practices.
You typically don't think about it
the other way around where somebody buys
something from you, you have to worry
about their information security
practices, but
this is an example of where.
If you're selling data about your
customers or other individuals
to other companies, well, maybe one
might need to look the other way around.
That was the Dun and Bradstreet breach.
Let me chat a little bit next
about the River City Media breach.
So River City Media is
an email marketing company.
And earlier this year, they had a list
of about 1.3 billion names and email
addresses that they would
typically market to.
And that data effectively was
a breach that effectively
inadvertently leaked out onto the Internet
because they were using a Unix
tool called RSYNC to back up their
database of email addresses.
There was a configuration problem with
that RSIC process, where it was set up so
that inadvertently allowed the information
to be viewable by anybody on the Internet.
So that was a second breach
that occurred this year.
The third issue that I want to talk about,
incident, that I want about for
this year is the WannaCry Incidents.
So WannaCry is the short form
of a name of a piece of malware,
malicious software, that would,
once it infects somebody's machine,
it would basically encrypt
files on the hard drive or
the local storage of
the machine that was infected.
It's a piece of ransomware.
So once that data got encrypted,
using that's only known to the attacker,
the attacker would then ask the individual
company that was affected to pay a ransom,
I believe it was about $300,
it was a few hundred dollars, if they
want to have their files decrypted.
So the WannaCry incident had affected over
200,000 machines across the internet,
and the reason that I say it
wasn't say an incident as opposed
to a breach is that typically in a breech,
there's an exfiltration
of the data in an unencrypted way.
In this case when WannaCry or another
piece of ransomware infects the machine,
it encrypts the data and keeps it
local to the machine that's infected.
And it doesn't necessarily need to
get infiltrated, and so that may or
may not qualify as a breach.
It certainly qualifies as a compromise,
but if you look at the various
state breach laws, and, I'll just mention
up front that I'm not an attorney,
it may or
may not qualify [LAUGH] as a breach.
But it's certainly
an interesting incident.
The reason that the WannaCry ransomware
was able to propagate and affect so
many machines on the internet
was because it took
advantage of a vulnerability in
a distributed file protocol,
the SMB protocol on Windows.
And what was interesting about this is
that the vulnerability that was used,
there was a patch made
available in mid-March.
And so if one simply patched
before it hit in May,
then one's machine should not be affected.
But it just emphasizes how
important regular patching is.
So those are three breaches slash
incidents that occurred just this year.
Now, if you look at some of these numbers,
if you look at the River City Media
breach, it has a very significant number,
1.34 billion.
It was mostly names and email addresses.
There have been larger breaches that have
been that have taken place over the years.
And more significant breaches in the way
of the information that was stolen.
So let me go ahead and chat a little bit
about some of those breaches as well.
Before I go on to talking
about specific breaches,
we'll start with the autumn
breach in just a second.
I just want to double click into
the diagram that I had on the previous
slide a little bit more.
This diagram shows the typical
attacker lifecycle.
So very often we can end
up focusing on our work and
what's convenient and
what we need to do to get our jobs done.
But attackers whether
they're cyber criminals,
whether they're nation state attackers,
they have a different view of the world.
And there's been a number of these types
of diagrams that have been produced over
the past few years.
This particular one is
available on Wikipedia.
But it shows that there is a cycle that
attackers follow where they first
define what their target is.
And then they effectively take
a mission based approach to going
about achieving their goals.
This is very different than way that
attackers used to operate 10 or
15 years ago.
Where very often somebody would write
a worm or a virus and deploy it out into
the internet and their goal was
just to make a name for themselves.
That's typically not the case anymore, the
attackers even when they make an initial
compromise they don't
disclose it to the world.
Even if they can deface your home page,
they don't do that right away.
They will look at the initial compromise
as a first step in their attack and
they'll figure out what else they can do.
And so once they've defined their target
they will figure out hey are there
other cybercriminal groups that
they want to work together with?
They may build or acquire tools to
target particular organizations.
They may develop custom malware.
They may understand a little bit
about how an organization works and
how to target their
particular countermeasures.
They will research their targets, whether
their targets be executives of a company,
whether their targets are system
administrators at a company.
They'll spend time on social networks
to understand who are the people they
should target, what are their roles?
If there's an important executive and
maybe they think the executive might not
fall for the attack,
who is their administrative assistant?
How can they
dupe the administrative assistant into
clicking on the wrong thing, for instance?
Once they develop their tools, they'll
test for detection, they'll deploy,
they'll make some initial intrusions,
they'll infect some machines.
They'll get credentials to
some particular account and
then they will continue their attack.
Once they establish a footprint
of a compromised machine, say,
they will initiate an up-down connection
that they can persistently control that
machine on an ongoing basis.
And use it as a beachhead to do
additional reconnaissance and
scanning to see what more
machines can they infect?
What other information
can they get access to?
And they'll pretty much continue
this process over months or
years until they accomplish their mission.
Whether their mission is to delve into
intellectual property, steal identities,
steal trade secrets,
and so on and so forth.
One of the things that this
diagram shows in the center,
is that not all attackers are equal.
There are some very determined attackers
that will put in that kind of effort and
they're typically referred to
as advanced persistent threats.
And so you'll see as denoted by the purple
that attackers that are in that category
will carry out all of the steps in this
particular attack lifecycle diagram.
At the same time there might be, say,
lower tier cybercriminal groups.
I wouldn't call them lower tier in their
methods of attack, but I call them lower
tier in, say, the amount of resources that
they have is compared to nation state.
And they may, in order to accomplish
their goals and their mission,
if they simply want to monetize
a bunch of machines that they infect.
And have them participate in a bot net and
rent out those compromised machines
to others, they may not need to pursue all
of the steps in this particular diagram.
So if you look at the orange for instance,
you'll see that they may build a required
tool they may test for
detection, they'll deploy.
But they may not spend as much time
researching via social media all of
the employees or individuals in
an organization that they want to target.
So this is the typical
attacker lifecycle and
as I talk about some of these large
breaches, you'll see they describe
some of the different parts of
this in talking about the attacks.
So, with that, let's talk about
the first breach or set of breaches.
And we're going to chat about the breaches
that occurred against Yahoo that was
discovered in 2016.
And so there's an asterisk
up to the top right of 2016,
because that's when
the attack was discovered.
The breaches actually took
place in 2013 and 2014,
there were actually two distinct breaches.
They disclosed one breach of over
500 million user records, and
then another follow on breach
of a billion plus user records.
And so just for convenience,
I will talk about those
breaches together as one, even though
they were two distinct breaches.
If we look at what information
was stolen in those user records,
it included not just names and
email addresses.
But it included telephone numbers,
it included the security questions and
answers that one typically sets up
when you set up a web based account.
Such that even if somebody didn't have
your password they could try to use
the answers to those questions
to gain access to your account.
The stolen information included dates
of birth as well as hacked passwords.
That said, due to the scope
of the breach that occurred,
what the attackers were able to do,
is get access to actually all
the billing across the Yahoo accounts.
And they were able to log into
any of those accounts at will,
without a password.
How did they do that?
I'll talk about that in just a second.
So this breach was the largest breach that
occurred in the history of the Internet.
Yahoo was in the midst
of getting acquired by
Verizon Communications at that time
that the breach was discovered.
And it was a breach that was material
enough, they were getting acquired,
I think, for $4 billion plus,
probably close to $5 billion.
And upon disclosure of the breach,
given that it was material,
Verizon dropped the price of
the acquisition by $350 million.
Which is pretty expensive in and
of itself,
not including all the costs that Yahoo
probably had to incur to do forensics,
and investigations, and
paying attorney's fees and whatnot.
It's a very significant breach,
probably the most significant
breach of all time, by far.
It resulted in
Issues to Yahoo's valuation.
Those were some of the impacts.
There are a number of
other impacts as well.
Given that attackers, and by the way,
the hacks that were conducted attacks
were made up of two Russian spies,
and two cyber criminals.
And one of the interesting
documents that I read,
of course in preparation for this webinar,
was the indictment of those individuals.
There's a reference to it
at the end of the talk, but
the attack was significant not only for
these financial reasons.
But the attackers given that they could
login to pretty much anybody's Yahoo
account, they started targeting diplomats,
they started targeted
particular executives.
They just went after about
6,500 very targeted folks.
Given, of course, that the list of
all of these records were stolen and
one could use them to do
math stop phishing attacks.
But there's many other things
that could've taken place.
The attackers used a combination of
spear phishing and malware to get in.
In fact, their attack was significant
enough that they were able to affect Yahoo
search engines so they could return
whatever links that they wanted at will.
And so in addition to the attacks that
they conducted, they setup a bunch of
affiliate deals and started serving
links on Yahoo search engine,
and monetizing the traffic from
people clicking onto those links.
So that's a pretty significant impact,
how did that occur?
So the FBI pretty much traced
the beginning of this attack
to a phishing attack.
In particular to a spear phishing attack.
So those of you who
are familiar with phishing.
You know that even going back ten years,
there would be
many attackers that would send out emails
that is claimed to be from some bank.
And they would hope that when
they sent you that email,
that you have an account at that bank and
that you'll click on the link and
you'll go to the imposter web
page that they've set up.
And enter your username and password for
your bank and the attacker's site
will just return some errors saying your
login didn't work please try again later.
But what the attacker will do with
those stolen credentials then
is go log into your bank and
try to transfer money out of it.
And those were kind of the initial
state of phishing attacks.
But over time attackers developed more
sophistication so that they started doing
spear phishing attacks where the attacks
were not necessarily targeted at
consumers broadly but they were targeted
at individuals and corporations.
And the goal was to get particular
individuals to give up their
credentials for certain corporate
accounts for corporate systems.
So, why bother trying to look for
vulnerabilities and
try to break in a whole bunch of machines
if you can just email an employee
and get them to give
you their credentials.
And so the attack against Yahoo in
fact started with spear phishing
against not an executive and
not random employees, but
a particular employee and set of
employees that were semi privileged,
that happened to have access
to certain systems at Yahoo.
Some of the key systems that
mattered were Yahoo's User Database,
and Yahoo's tool that they used for
account management.
The results though, another tool
that was used to generate cookies.
And so let me just finish talking a little
bit about spear phishing and malware.
I know I've talked a little bit about
how the cookie theft occurred and
how that allowed hackers to
access all Yahoo email accounts.
So spear phishing attacks, they very often
are seeking to steal a set of user
credentials, and employee credentials.
But in addition given that drive by
downloads can occur where to infect
a machine these days, you don't even
need to dupe a user into clicking yes,
or downloading something and
double clicking on it to run.
You can simply, if you can send over
an email where you can dupe somebody
into just clicking on a link.
Then upon the victim clicking on a link,
they will get infected just
by opening the web page.
And the way that happens is by drive
by download where the infected web
page will fingerprint what
browser is the victim running.
What are all the different third party
plugins that the victim is running.
And within a couple hundred milliseconds
the attacker's exploit tool kit on
the infected web page figures out
what vulnerable versions of software
are running.
And simply does a lookup in an online
database to figure out what's the piece
of malicious code that they need to
spin down to exploit that vulnerability,
infect the machine, and take it over.
And so spear phishing attacks often also
contain these links to drive by downloads.
So the attacks against Yahoo
started with spear phishing and
malware that was used to infect machines.
And the attacker was able to get
access to these Yahoo systems.
I mentioned that one of the systems
was a tool that allows the attacker to
effectively mint cookies.
So for those of you that
know how both websites work,
right if there's a website
which requires a login.
You present the user with a username and
password field and
have them type in the username and
password.
And then once their username and password
checks out, you give them back a cookie,
and a server will give back
a cookie to the user's browser.
And after that interaction it's that
cookie that keeps going back and
forth between the website and
the users browser and
that cookie actually
authenticates the user.
So that the user doesn't have
to enter their username and
password on every single web page.
And so, well, if you're an attacker and
you can figure out how a website creates
its cookies, then you actually don't
need anybody's password to login,
you can just forge cookies.
And login to the website and
go from there.
And that's exactly what
happened in the Yahoo attack.
And that's how the attackers were able to
access all Yahoo email accounts at will,
without passwords.
So that's the Yahoo breach.
And that was discovered in 2016.
I'm going to talk about a couple of other
breaches that were discovered in 2015 and
2014, and then I'm going to chat
a little bit about some defenses
against malware and phishing.
But one thing that you'll see is that
in a lot of these breaches phishing and
malware have been the tools of choice
that attackers have been using.
So let me chat about the next breach,
the Office of Personnel Management
breach of 2015.
The Office of Personnel Management
is a government agency that has or
had and still has,
all the background check records.
So anytime you applied to be a government
employee and or have to go through
a security clearance, there is a form
called SF86, standard form 86.
And it not only contains, as you might
imagine, all the previous addresses that
you used to live and all the places
that you used to work and what not.
But it has that information for
all of your family members.
And what got stolen during the Office
of Personnel Management breach
in 2015 was all of those records.
It also included, by the way,
5.6 million finger print records.
And so.
What with the impact of that attack.
If you read these health
oversight committees
majority staff report on this breach,
a direct quote from there,
in terms of what the impact was is that it
will harm counter intelligence efforts for
at least a generation to come.
The value of the stolen
background information for
a foreign nation cannot be overstated,
nor will it ever be fully known.
That's quite significant,
the damage has already been done.
It's a significant blow to
a country's intelligence efforts, and
counterintelligence efforts.
How did it happen?
Overall, the information security program
at the Office of Personnel Management was
under resourced and the amount of priority
that was given to security was not enough.
The US Computer Emergency Response Team
had actually
identified that there was an exfiltration
from the Office of Personnel Management.
It was kind of part of breach one.
They notified the Office of Personnel
Management and basically, a set of teams
were set up to monitor the first breach,
and then there was a second breach.
But basically it was a,
even after that first breach occurred,
it was discovered that there was
malware on a number of key machines,
including I believe, a jump box.
A jump box is typically a machine
that's in between ones that are in
the development and test the staging
network for one's production network.
And that machine that was infected,
seemed to be
running a process,
a dynamically linked library.
That had a particular
name that was actually
indicative of McAfee Security software.
Unfortunately, the OPM was
not a McAfee customer.
That was simply a piece of malware and
a name being used to masquerade
the attacker's tool kit.
They were using a root
kit called HighKick.
And that malware was used to
reportedly monitor accounts and
steal more information.
So, the program there
was then resourced and
there was a sequence of breaches.
One of the things that could
have been done to prevent
this breach was to use multi
factor authentication.
So that even if say some
machines got infected and
even if some account credentials
got stolen from there.
If you require more than
just a username and
password to access certain critical
systems, then and say there's some two
factor code that gets sent to
the person's mobile phone or whatnot.
Then the attacker would've had to infect
not only a bunch of machines, but
also people's phones.
So that could've potentially helped.
One of the challenges that the Office of
Personnel Management had was they had
a lot of legacy systems.
And keeping legacy systems patched so
that they can't be affected by
malware can often be a challenge.
So that's a little bit about the Office
of Personnel Management breach.
Going back a year, or
actually also in 2015,
let me also chat about the Anthem breach.
Anthem provides healthcare services to
a significant fraction of the country.
And in 2015 they had a breach where 80
million customer records were stolen.
Those records included people's names,
their dates of birth,
their Social Security numbers,
their healthcare ID's.
And there have been more than
100 lawsuits that occurred.
In this particular case,
there was a database user's
credentials that were stolen.
And the way the breach got noticed
is that one of the administrators
had noticed that there was a database
inquiry running that they didn't issue.
And so the issue I think occurred, the
initial compromise might've happened in
say April, but in December or January,
months later this query was noticed to
be running and it was taking
up a lot of system resources.
And so once it was investigated.
That the credentials were stolen.
It set off the whole
incident response process.
I have a next slide here on how the Anthem
breach happened in more detail.
And we'll return to how it could
have been prevented in just a bit.
Basically, there were a couple steps,
the attacker sent in a phishing
email with a link to Wellpoint.com.
We11point spelled with two
ones instead of two Ls.
The victim clicked on it.
The victim machine got
infected just from the click.
Malware was installed in
the victims system and
then that system got monitored, right?
Once the attacker owns the system,
they can monitor all traffic that goes
through it and they were able to
monitor for account credentials.
So what happened from there is that
the attacker stole the credentials and
used those credentials to start posting
queries against Anthem's databases and
then issued a query for
this 80 million data set.
And that's the point at which
the attacker got discovered.
So, that's the Anthem Breach.
I'll talk about just one or
two more breaches.
I'll talk about the JPMorgan Chase
breach that happened in 2014.
In this particular breach, what got
stolen was 70 million customer names and
email addresses.
One of the things that was
interesting about this breach,
if you could imagine that JPMorgan Chase,
as a bank invests a lot in security.
And this kind of information stolen,
it can be used for
mass potential phishing attacks.
Of course,
because the attacker stole the information
from this dataset at JPMorgan and Chase.
They know that all the customers
had JPMorgan Chase accounts.
So there is that potential for
mass phishing attacks, but
given that it impacted a bank,
one of the silver linings here in this
particular breach is that one could
imagine that if it was worse.
The attackers could have just directly
stolen money out of people's accounts, or
deleted information, or just took direct
financial control, which didn't happen.
So it's unfortunate that
the attack occurred, but
it could have been a lot worse.
How did this particular attack occur?
Again, there was a phishing email that was
sent to steal some employee credentials.
Then those employee credentials
were leveraged by the attacker.
Now JPMorgan Chase did have two factor
authentication deployed on many,
many, many of their servers.
Unfortunately, there was one third party
server that was a nonprofit that did
some work for the bank.
I believe that they helped
organize fundraisers,
marathons, something like that.
But basically there was one server on
which two factor authentication was not
deployed.
And so the attacker was able
to use the stolen username and
password to get to this data.
So, what could have prevented it?
Well, anti-phishing training.
If employees can be better trained
to recognize phishing attacks and or
more quickly report them,
so much the better.
And, of course, you've gotta
get two factors on all servers.
If you miss even one,
attackers can take advantage of that.
Now the JPMorgan Chase breach.
And finally,
I'll talk about the Target breach.
In the Target breach in 2013, what got
stolen was 40 million credit card numbers,
that's the bad news.
The good news is that you can reset
people's credit card numbers, and
customers are typically not
held accountable or liable.
But the way that this
occurred was actually
initially via a third-party
supplier that Target used.
They had a firm by the name of Fazio
Mechanical Services that was responsible
for running the air conditioning and
heating at all of the retail branches.
And the attacker first broke into
faulty mechanical services and
took advantage of the fact that their
networks were connected together.
And they started sending out a whole
bunch of malware-laden phishing emails,
and over a series of months, basically
got to a point where they were able to,
with malware, infect the point of sale
stations that were in the retail stores.
And they were able to start
exfiltrating data out of those point
of sale stations as customers
would scan their cards.
So, in this particular case, network
segmentation could've helped if their air
conditioning network access was segmented
off from the rest of the company's access,
that could've helped deterred
the attackers further.
And Target did have some
anti-malware technology deployed.
They had a set of folks
outsourced abroad that were
kind of looking through all the alerts.
And there were a significant number
of alerts that indicated that there
was a breach going on, there were
malware infections taking place.
Some of those notifications were getting
escalated up to their headquarters, but
there were so
many alerts that they couldn't and
weren't able to respond to them.
And there might have been enough false
positive alerts, fake alarms effectively,
that it may have been hard to discern,
well what were the real alerts?
Where was the real malicious
activity happening?
So, in any case, that surveyed a whole
bunch of the big-name breaches that
have taken place over the past four years.
I'm going to talk about some of
the key attack vectors and defenses.
In all of these big name attacks,
phishing and malware have been used as
tools of choice by the attackers, so I'm
going to talk about a bunch of defenses.
When it comes to phishing,
I mentioned that one of the things that
you can do is train your employees,
give them awareness training, for
how to recognize phishing attacks.
How do you recognize malicious domains?
How do you recognize malicious URLs?
And in many organizations,
one good practice is to regularly
try to phish your own employees.
The security team sends out
fake phishing emails and
sees what percentage of the employees
fall for the test attack.
And then continue quarter over quarter,
year over year with helping
the employee base just get better and
better at recognizing such attacks.
One of the interesting things that can
happen in those things is that when you
train employees to recognize attacks and
then have them start sending in attacks,
what can happen from time to time is
they'll send in an email saying, ha, ha,
ha, you tried to get me with your
fake attack, but I caught you.
And sometimes the email response that
comes back from the security team
is actually, that wasn't us,
that was a real attack.
So thank you for being a human
sensor to complement all of our
technology to help us gather data
on when we're getting attacked.
Part of such training that is
important is to recognize and
train employees to report phishing attacks
because once phishing attacks do occur,
it's not necessarily game over.
If some user did get duped into providing
their user name and password and
then reports it in, well, security
team can help reset those credentials.
So that the credentials that
got stolen are unaffected, or
let's say that somebody's system
got infected with malware.
Well, you can take steps to contain that
malware and reimage your machine and
cut off the attacks.
But there's gotta be that training.
So the fast reporting of
credentials is important.
Other technologies that can be important
in making email more secure Is
leveraging technologies like SPF and
DKIM and DMARC that in SPF,
you can declare, well, what are the.
You can imagine that attackers.
If you're working for
a company called fubar.com,
attackers might want to spoof
emails coming from that domain so
that it appears like it's
coming from the organization.
And by using technologies like SPF and
DKIM and DMARC and by assigning all emails
that go out from the organization and
instructing the internet
to drop such emails, you can make it much,
much harder for attackers
to try to spoof your own domain and
kind of force them to use other domains.
And so then, if users have
the appropriate training, to look out for
spammy looking domains, it can help.
And then another important defense is to
leverage multi-factor authentication so
that even if attackers steal a particular
username and password credential,
that credential in and of itself cannot
be used to access a critical system and
it requires another two factor
code to come via another out
of band channel in order to
provide access to a system.
Some phishing and some defenses,
and then there's malware.
Having important anti-malware
defenses is very important.
And it's actually important to go beyond
just traditional antivirus which might use
signature-based techniques to recognize
malware that's been already deployed.
But you ought to defend against Malware
that hasn't been recognized yet.
So various input production products
on the market, in addition to using
signatures, they'll use heuristics,
they'll use machine learning,
they'll leverage cloud intelligence from
samples that have come in from customers
to achieve a network effect in detection,
those are all good detectives.
In addition, when there's any
piece of executable code that
looks like it might be suspicious,
one can leverage what's called
sandbox based detection where that malware
gets spun up into a virtual machine.
And you test,
well what does that binary do?
So even if there's no signature for it,
maybe if it sets off some heuristics,
you say well, what does it actually do
when it starts running on a machine?
There's also intrusion detection
technology that can be used,
such as Norton Pro, that are well
known intrusion detection systems,
which do take advantage of signatures, but
basically gives you detection
not just on the host themselves,
but at the network layer, at the firewall
layer and other parts of the network.
And then one other thing that you can do
is on machines that could potentially get
infected, limit the privileges that users
are allowed to have on their machines.
You can imagine that if you can limit
privileges and say not let users install
software on their machines, then If even
some attacker compromises that machine,
they won't be able to
install malicious software.
So limiting the privileges
can be important.
I talked about the attack against Yahoo.
So it is important, if you run web
applications to make sure that the cookies
that your site generates are strong.
And very often what goes into cookies,
they get generated based
off of some secret key or
some combination of a secret key
plus a per user [INAUDIBLE].
So it's important to protect those keys,
have strong key management.
And all these topics are topics covered in
a number of our courses here at Stanford.
Let me chat a little bit about
some sensors more generally.
I've talked a lot about
the big name breaches here.
Phishing and malware have been a set
of tools that attackers have used to
accomplish these big name breaches.
But you know,
most breaches in fact because of mistakes
made by employees or some set of humans.
And so it's important to not
just have anti malware and
anti-phising defenses, but
to have a set of defenses,
that when employees at an organization
to have a holistic defense.
And to have countermeasures that
defend not only against the most
sophisticated cyber criminals,
these kind of big name types of attacks.
But also defend against all
the inadvertent things that can go wrong.
And so employing an approach where you
have some countermeasures that prevent
,is a good thing.
For instance, data minimization, if you
don't need the data, don't store it.
If you don't store it, it can't be stolen.
There is a whole bunch of other
prevention approaches that's here.
But you got a couple back
together with good detection,
good containment and
good recovery counter measures.
How one reacts when there's issues can be
just as important as preventing issues
in and of themselves, is one of the things
that's been learned over the years.
If you're an organization and you're
working to improve your security and
monitor your security,
how can you do that?
And how can you do that quantitatively?
So, there's a number of services
these days that allow you to measure
your security posture.
And so the SecurityScorecard is a company
that's funded by Google Ventures.
They provide one such service where
they measure ten different areas of your
security.
And for instance they measure
your end point security,
they help identify if you do have infected
machines on your network that might
be participating in bot nets,
networks of compromised machines.
And they do that by monitoring
the bot networks and
what IP they're connecting in them.
And are any of those IP addresses yours?
But employer service like this
can help you get a sense for
your overall security posture and
can be very good in helping you figure
out where you need to make improvements.
One of the challenges, of course,
is that such things may not
be fully comprehensive.
For instance are you using
two factor authentication?
Are you doing phishing tests and
anti-phishing training?
That may or may not be directly
captured by some of these
measurements in a number of these areas.
A typical security score card
though will have a lot of data.
It'll have some overview that gives you
grades in these different areas and
helps you monitor the data over time.
This is a sample report for a fictional
organization called Evergrocery,
but can be helpful.
For instance, looking at patching seasons.
If you have any machines that are not
being patched regularly externally,
then it could be susceptible
to incidents like WannaCry.
So this kind of data can be helpful.
Another such tool that could
be used is a tool called
QuadMetrics that was
acquired actually by FICO,
the same organization that
monitors credit scores.
And the reason I mention QuadMetrics
is because they are also looking at
what are many of
the different features and
aspects that one can observe to
assess external security posture.
And I mentioned them because they have
some published researched back in 2015,
a number of the early employees and
the founders I believe of
the company published a paper at
the [INAUDIBLE] security symposium.
And in their paper they
described how they looked at 258
features that one can just observe and
see if there's any mismanagement happening
within an organization's security.
Are there SSL certificates
that are misconfigured?
Are some of the IPs that
an organization owns involved in doing.
They're having phishing attacks and
they built a random forest predictive
classifier, so that they could
predict which organizations
are most likely to get breached.
Without getting into the details we cover
this in more detail in our cyber security
for executives course.
They trained some of their models and
then looked at well back in 2014,
could they predict which organizations
might've gotten breached?
And based on the way the classifier was
trained, it came up with pretty high
scores for some of the organizations
that were breached.
Now of course the real question
is if we use this model today.
Who they predict is going to get breached
next year and the year after that.
But it's really good to see the field
getting more quantitative and
bringing in more data to help
assess security posture and
help organizations improve their security.
So with that, I'll just provide a couple
of pointers where you can learn more.
I mentioned the Cyber Security and
Executive Strategy course
that we just rolled out.
That helps you as a manager or
as an executive understand,
how do you measure security?
How do you report to the board?
How you report to other management.
We have a course on emerging
threats on defenses.
We also have a course on
software security foundations.
So if you are just getting into
the field and want to learn more,
that's a great course to take.
There's a bunch of other links here to
some resources on the various breaches
that I talked about.
For instance, a link to the indictment
of the Russian spy with cyber criminals.
In the case of the OPM breach there's a
link here to this house oversight majority
staff report.
There's a link to a presentation by
some folks from Anthem themselves about
that how that attack occurred.
And with that I hope you have
enjoyed learning how these big
name breaches have occurred.
And hope that you've enjoyed learning
a little bit about some of the counter
measures that could help in
how the breaches occurred.
So that hopefully we can all
learn from these lessons and
prevent some of these kinds of
breaches from occurring in the future.
Thank you.
>> All right, so now we'll take a few
minutes to answer some of your questions.
Looks like the first one we have is,
with breaches being a part
of the mainstream media in the past
few years, particularly politics,
security has now become a much
higher priority for my company.
We have recently been approved for
a significant budget increase next year.
And are discussing proposed strategies.
What areas do you think will
provide the best investment?
>> So, that is a question that will
depend upon your organization and
what, who's targeting you,
what's your attack surface.
And so, to figure out what might
be some of the best areas for
investment, what I suggest is,
as step one,
to do a risk assessment, and
have interviews with their employees,
have bringing a lot of quantitative and
qualitative data and
access what the risks are.
And then, figure out what are the counter
measures, whether it be people, profit,
technology that what's put in place,
to address those risks.
That's the first question,
let me take a stab at the next question.
Next question here is,
can we define breach?
I've heard this word used
in different places, but
I don't know the exact meaning?
For example,
is breach mean data is compromised, or
when it only refers to
certain sets of standards?
And so,
the question of what is the definition
of breach is an interesting one.
I would actually encourage
you to consult an attorney.
There are data breach laws in 45,
47 plus of the states that have them and
they all define breach
a little bit differently.
The definition, again,
of California was the first state that
had such a database fallback in 2003.
But the law is generally around the form
that if there is unencrypted data that's
stolen that contains, say, somebody's
name, or certain type of identifiers,
whatever, then it counts as a breach.
And each state's definitions
are a little bit different.
And there's that legal
definition of a breach.
Sometimes, I've seen technical
folks throw around the word breach.
But first it's,
let's say that infect some system.
Well, if there's no customer or
personal identifiable information,
that may not be considered a breach.
So, the answer is consult an attorney.
An attorney will help you understand
what's the legal definition of breach,
and go from there.
I think we have time for
maybe one more question.
And let's see,
I can only choose, I guess, one.
Let's see, there's a question here of,
I have a question about the attack on.
How long could this hacker maintain
connectivity with the victim in terms
of duration?
The answer to that is that
an attacker could, in theory,
maintain connectivity indefinitely until
the connectivity is cut off for
some reason.
So, how long an attacker wants
to maintain connectivity,
how fast can an organization identify it
and cut it off, those are all variables.
But there is nothing
inherent about the attack on
that would limit how long an attacker
can maintain connectivity.
And so, with attacks having
become more mission-based,
the attackers have been
maintaining connectivity
much longer than they have in the past.
It can range on the order of months or
years.
>> Well, great, thank you so much, Neil.
Looks like that's all the time
we have left for this webinar.
Thank you all for joining us, and
we hope you have a great rest of your day.